en este vídeo vamos a ver algunos
ejemplos de cómo se resuelven las
ecuaciones van a ser ecuaciones muy
sencillas los pasos van a ser muy
fáciles pero lo que realmente quiero que
quede claro en este vídeo es porque
hacemos los pasos que hacemos cuando
estamos tratando de resolver una
ecuación entonces empecemos con el
primer ejemplo x + 11 es igual a 7 en
esta ecuación déjame la vuelvo a
escribir x + 11 es igual a 7 ok
aquí lo que estamos buscando es qué
número cuando se lo sumamos a 11 nos da
7 y seguramente puedes obtener la
respuesta rapidísimo ahorita haciéndolo
en tu cabeza pero vamos a hacerlo paso a
paso de una forma sistemática para que
cuando estamos resolviendo ecuaciones
mucho más complicadas sea más fácil
saber exactamente qué es lo que tenemos
que hacer aunque entonces cuando
queremos resolver una ecuación como este
lo que realmente queremos hacer es
encontrar cuál es este valor de la x
ok queremos llegar a algo de la forma x
es igual a y aquí
un número que si lo colocamos justo en
el lugar de la equis se satisface esta
ecuación que es el número 11
realmente es igual a 7 ahora para
encontrar esta x pues ya tenemos
bastante no sea ya tenemos que una está
x más este 11 es igual as en este caso 7
entonces lo único que necesitamos para
encontrar a que es igual a x es
deshacernos de este más 11 que nos
queremos deshacer de éste más 11 pero
pues no podemos simplemente tacharlo por
acá para deshacernos de lo que podemos
hacer es restarle 11 ok
hoy le estamos sumando menos 11 pero si
le estamos sumando menos 11 a este lado
del igual pues también se lo tenemos que
sumar a este lado del igual porque si no
este signo de igual que nos está
diciendo que esta cosa es igual a esta
cosa ya no nos estaría diciendo algo
verdadero ok lo que realmente tenemos
aquí
que x más 11 o sea todo esto es igual a
7 ok eso es lo que nosotros sabemos que
es cierto estas dos cantidades son
iguales y si nosotros queremos que esta
igualdad se preserva y le queremos sumar
un -11 al lado izquierdo del igual
entonces también tenemos que sumarle un
-11 a este lado del igual porque
entonces en el fondo lo que estamos
diciendo es que cualquier cosa que le
hagamos al lado izquierdo del igual se
lo tenemos que hacer al lado derecho del
igual para que sigan siendo iguales y
sigamos pudiendo poner este símbolo de
igual entonces empecemos por el lado
izquierdo de esta igualdad tenemos aquí
menos 11 más x más 11 que es lo mismo
que x más 11 menos 11 o sea x + 0 que es
simplemente una equis y eso es igual a 7
menos 11 y resolver está resta es muy
sencillo si no te acuerdas vamos a poner
una
recta numérica tenemos aquí el 0 y
entonces saltamos a la derecha siete
veces uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete este es el siete y ahora soltamos
hacia la izquierda 11 veces 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 veces entonces 7 unos 11 es
este lugar en la recta numérica que es
saber aquí tenemos el 0 - 1 - 2 - 3 y
menos 4 aunque entonces x es igual a
menos 4 x es igual a menos 4 entonces ya
terminamos con la primera ecuación y
encontramos a cuánto es igual esta x así
es que vamos con la siguiente ecuación y
aquí lo que tenemos es que 7 x x es
igual a 21 gay esta es otra ecuación
distinta esta esta x no tiene porqué
tener nada que ver con ésta
aunque hay entonces vamos a empezar por
reescribir esta ecuación
7 x x es igual a 21 y lo que estamos
buscando es algo de esta forma o sea
tenemos aquí x igual a alguna otra cosa
donde en este caso esa otra cosa cuando
la multiplicamos por 7 nos da 21 aunque
estamos buscando que el número debería
de ir aquí a que es igual esta x haber y
aquí lo que tengo es 7 por x si yo fuera
dividir esta expresión entre un 7
entonces lo que tengo es 7 por alguna
cosa dividido entre 7 y eso sea cual sea
esta cosa es simplemente esta cosa
cierto y entonces ya tenemos aquí a la
equis solita de este lado del igual
ahora si yo divido el lado izquierdo del
igual entre 7 entonces también tengo que
dividir el lado derecho del igual entre
7 aunque hay todo lo que le hagamos al
lado izquierdo se lo tenemos que hacer
al lado derecho
ok entonces ya que tenemos esta igualdad
así x por 7 entre 7 eso es simplemente
una equis y esto es igual a 21 entre 7 3
por 7 21 entonces aquí lo que va es un 3
21 entre 7 es igual a 3
así es que x es igual a 3 y podemos
verificar que tenemos el resultado
correcto y para hacer eso lo único que
tenemos que hacer es en esta ecuación
sustituir a x ok entonces en todos los
lugares de esta ecuación donde aparece
el x que o sea aquí tenemos que escribir
un 3 y verificar que realmente se dé
esta igualdad pero si se da esta
igualdad no sea porque aquí en lugar de
una x ponemos un 3 y entonces aquí lo
que tenemos es que 7 por 3 es igual a 21
y eso sí hacía tono entonces está muy
bien eso de que x sea igual a 3
y lo mismo podemos hacer con esta
ecuación que nosotros estamos diciendo
que x es igual a menos 4 para
verificarlo pues aquí en lugar de la x
podemos poner un -4 y ver que realmente
esto sea igual a esto pero eso sí es
cierto porque menos cuatro más once eso
es igual a 11 menos 4 y eso sí es igual
a 7
entonces x si es igual a menos 4 bien
ahora vamos con la siguiente y se ve
como que es una ecuación un poquito más
complicada pero vas a ver que está súper
sencilla aunque hay entonces tenemos
5 x entre 12 es igual a dos tercios
entonces qué te parece si multiplicamos
por dos quintos ok ahora sí lo quiero
hacer de este lado del igual entonces
para preservar este signo de igual
también lo tengo que hacer del lado
derecho del igual o sea que quitan que
multiplicar por 12 quintos ahora para
que quería yo multiplicar por 12 quinto
pues resulta que si multiplicas por 12
quintos a la hora de hacer esta
multiplicación este 12 se va a cancelar
con este 12 y este 5 se va a cancelar
con este 5 y entonces aquí nos queda
simplemente esta x que nos queda la
equis igual a dos tercios por dos y
quintos ahora este 12 también lo podemos
ver como un 3 por 4 3 por 4 y entonces
este 3 se va a cancelar con este 3
y nos queda simplemente 2 por 4 entre 5
o sea ocho quintos entonces x es igual a
ocho quintos ahora aquí tú puedes saltar
y decirme y sal oye aquí estás haciendo
otra cosa distinta a lo que estás
haciendo aquí aquí este el coeficiente
de la equis es un 7 porque ahí el
coeficiente es el número por el cual
estás multiplicando a la equis en este
caso y bueno aquí lo que hace es para
resolver esta ecuación es dividir entre
el coeficiente de la x de los dos lados
del igual aunque mientras que en este
caso en lugar de dividir entre el
coeficiente de la x que en este caso es
512 a vos lo que haces es multiplicar
por el inverso del coeficiente que el
inverso de 512 a 2 es 12 quintos y aquí
estamos multiplicando por 12 quintos en
lugar de dividir entre 5 12 a 2
pero bueno resulta que estos dos métodos
son exactamente equivalentes las dos son
muy buenas formas de resolver ecuaciones
y por ejemplo aquí en lugar de dividir
entre 7 podríamos haber multiplicado por
el inverso de 7 aunque si tenemos por
aquí 7 x igual a 21 podemos en lugar de
dividir entre 7 de los dos lados del
igual podemos simplemente multiplicar
por el inverso de 7 ok el inverso de 7
es ese número que si lo multiplicamos
por 7 nos da 1 entonces multiplicamos de
este lado así es que tenemos que
multiplicar de este lado también por 1
entre 7 y entonces 1 entre 7 por 7 eso
se cancela
y nos queda simplemente una equis igual
a 21 por 1 entre 7 eso es simplemente 21
entre 7 que es igual a 3 que hay
entonces x es igual a 32 formas
distintas de resolver esta ecuación nos
dieron exactamente el mismo resultado
y también se puede hacer con esta
ecuación entonces tenemos por aquí 52
seamos de x a ver a ver esta cantidad es
exactamente igual a esta cantidad ok lo
único que hice fue separar la x del
coeficiente gay 5 por x entre 12 es
exactamente igual a 5 entre 12 x x ok y
entonces tenemos aquí que la ecuación es
5 doceavos x x es igual a dos tercios
pero ahora en lugar de multiplicar por
el inverso de 512 abós que es 12 quintos
lo que vamos a hacer es dividir a todo
entre 512 ambos ok si dividimos el lado
izquierdo también tenemos que dividir
el lado derecho bueno pero resulta que
estas cantidades son exactamente iguales
a estas cantidades porque resulta que
divide entre una fracción es exactamente
igual a multiplicar por el inverso de
esa fracción aunque si queremos resolver
esta división lo que hacemos es la regla
del sándwich que lo que hace es pasar
este para que multiplicando y este para
que multiplicando aunque ahí esa es la
regla del sándwich y eso es exactamente
igual a multiplicar por 12 quintos
entonces finalmente no importa si lo que
haces es dividir entre el coeficiente de
la equis o multiplicar por el inverso
del coeficiente de la equis gay estas
dos operaciones son exactamente
equivalentes entonces pues vamos a
seguir haciendo ejemplos
ahora vamos a resolver estas ecuaciones
y todas estas ecuaciones en realidad las
vamos a hacer para que quede muy claro
que no sólo podemos resolver ecuaciones
que tengan x arriba teníamos un bonche
de ecuaciones con una variable x que
queríamos encontrar y aquí lo que
tenemos son un bonche de ecuaciones con
por ejemplo una q una zeta una s y lo
que vamos a hacer es encontrar cuánto
tiene que valer q para que se dé esta
igualdad o cuánto tiene que ser zeta
para qué se hace tales sumas 1.1 entre
que de 3.000 1 o cuánto tiene que valer
la s para que esta igualdad sea cierta
ok entonces empecemos por la q aquí lo
que tenemos es que q menos 13 es igual a
menos 13
y lo que queremos es encontrar esta q
queremos dejar a esta acuso lista para
que nos quede una igualdad de la forma q
es igual a otra cosa por allí ok si
llegamos a esto ya resolvimos esta
ecuación ósea ya encontramos cuánto vale
q y como le vamos a hacer para dejar
solita la cruz gay como nos vamos a
deshacer de este menos 13 pues qué te
parece si aquí le sumamos 13 ok sumamos
13 del lado izquierdo del igual entonces
tenemos que sumar 13 del lado derecho
del igual y para que dice eso pues
porque 13 más menos 13 o sea 13 13 es
igual a 0 y entonces aquí nos queda 0 +
q o sea que nos queda la q solita del
lado izquierdo del ibal ok 13 más como
menos 13 es simplemente una q y eso como
seguimos la regla de que todo lo que le
hagamos al lado izquierdo se lo tenemos
que hacer al lado derecho entonces
o sea que es exactamente igual a menos
13 13 lo cual es simplemente un 0 aunque
hay entonces q es igual a cero
y podemos verificarlo sustituyendo a que
en esta igualdad si es que tenemos q
igual a cero
0 - 13 - 13 igualdad menos 13 y si
definitivamente menos 13 si es igual a
menos 13 aunque entonces
y listo
y se nos olvidó chequear el inciso
anterior porque entonces eso es lo más
padre de álgebra siempre puedes checar
tu respuesta si es que tienes tiempo
suficiente
ok una vez que encuentras la respuesta
siempre puedes checar si es la respuesta
correcta ok entonces vamos a ver aquí
nosotros estamos diciendo que la
respuesta correcta es ocho quintos así
es que lo que estamos diciendo es que 5
entre 12 por 8 quintos es igual a dos
tercios
aunque el 5 con el 5 se cancelen el 12
lo podemos ver como un 4 por 3 el 8 lo
podemos ver como un 4 por 2 entonces
este 2 se cancela con este 2 y nos queda
simplemente este 3 y este 2 sea que nos
queda dos tercios dos tercios así es que
si está si es la respuesta correcta muy
bien qué bueno que chequeamos ahora si
vamos con este ejercicio
entonces tenemos z + 1.1 es igual a
3.000 1 ok
bien queremos encontrar a cuánto es
igual esta z aunque queremos algo de la
forma zeta es igual a tanto entran la
respuesta pero para hacer eso tenemos
que deshacernos de este 1.1 entonces yo
propongo que restamos 1.1 de los dos
lados recuerda muy importante nosotros
sabemos que esto es exactamente igual a
esto y si queremos preservar esta
igualdad entonces si le sumamos algo a
este lado del igual también solo tenemos
que sumar a este otro lado aunque hay
cualquier cosa que se nos ocurra hacerle
a este lado del igual se lo tenemos que
hacer a este lado del igual para seguir
teniendo una igualdad que entonces aquí
estamos sumando este con este y hacemos
eso porque es
y más este se van a cancelar 1.1 menos
1.1 se cancelan entonces nada más nos
queda la zeta
así es que tenemos que z es igual a
3.000 uno menos 1.1 y sabes que creo que
hacer esta operación es la parte más
difícil de resolver esta ecuación
entonces vamos a hacerla con calma
tenemos aquí 3.000 uno menos 1.1 lo que
queremos hacer aquí es alinear el punto
decimal
así es que ponemos el punto decimal
justo por aquel entonces tenemos por
aquí un 1.1 y lo estamos restando y de
hecho podemos agregar todos los ceros
que queremos a la derecha del punto
decimal entonces aquí tenemos uno menos
cero eso es un 1
0 - 0 eso es un 0 0 0 0 y aquí es donde
se pone interesante
0 - 1 pues lo que tenemos que hacer es
todo ese relajo de pedirle prestado a
las unidades de la izquierda entonces
aquí en lugar de tener un 3 vamos a
tener un 2 y aquí en lugar de tener cero
unidades vamos a tener 10 unidades y
entonces 10 menos 1 nos quedan 9 y 2
menos uno nos queda 1 entonces nuestra
respuesta es que z es igual a 1.900 1 y
podemos verificar esta respuesta muy
fácilmente tenemos aquí zeta ceta
entonces le sumamos 1.1 y queremos ver
si eso es igual a tres puntos 0001
entonces vamos a sumar
alineamos los decimales aquí tenemos 1.1
estamos sumando
entonces 0 1 1
0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 19 eso es 10 o sea que
aquí ponemos un 0 y ponemos un 1 por acá
pero llevamos 1 el punto decimal y
finalmente uno más uno más uno que
llevábamos eso es 3 que definitivamente
sí es igual a 3.001 así es que muy bien
ya verificamos esta si es una respuesta
correcta y vamos con el siguiente el
último ejercicio nuestra última ecuación
tenemos aquí que 21 por s es igual a
tres que y entonces tenemos que 21 por
algo que queremos encontrar es igual a 3
así es que para encontrar ese algo lo
que podemos hacer es multiplicar por 1
entre 21 de los dos lados del igual
entonces 1 entre 21 y el 21 se cancelan
porque 21 entre 21 es igual a 1 entonces
uno por s y nos queda ese es igual a 3
por 1 entre 21 que es 3 entre 21 que a
su vez es igual a 21 es 3 por 7 no
entonces aquí tenemos 1 entre 7 que
podemos verificar que ese es igual a 1
entre 7 sustituyendo a ese en esta
ecuación que entonces tenemos aquí 21
por 1 entre 7 y eso es igual a 3 si es
que
es igual a 1 entre 7 es la respuesta
correcta muy bien espero que encuentres
este vídeo muy útil y nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo